convicted on trumped-up charges in a
court the world doesn't recognize now
facing the death penalty sean pinner and
aiden aslan's treatment is causing
outrage among international law experts
i think they've been treated in in in an
appalling uh uh and probably i guess a
falsely criminal manner and a manner
that clearly uh uh
is completely against the rules of war
geneva convention
and the sort of fairness that we'd hope
and expect uh competence to be treated
ukraine has also put prisoners on trial
for war crimes a tank commander who shot
a civilian in cold blood and soldiers
who fired rockets into residential areas
it set a precedent russia has now
followed but also given ukraine pawns it
could swap with pina and aslan if they
want to but russia may be after this man
instead pro-russian ukrainian oligarch
victor medvedchuk has publicly asked to
be exchanged with the two british men
and is a personal friend of vladimir
putin's
it's thought britain may be privately
trying to negotiate a prisoner swap for
the two condemned britons while publicly
expressing outrage the foreign secretary
liz trust tweeting i utterly condemn the
sentencing of aiden aslin and sean
pinner held by russian proxies in
eastern ukraine they are prisoners of
war this is a sham judgment with
absolutely no
legitimacy but war crimes experts say
the uk should also threaten to prosecute
those imposing today's sentence in the
international criminal court that anyone
involved in the
in the
alleged trial process and in any alleged
execution could himself or herself be
brought to trial by the icc because that
would be if it's an unlawful killing of
a combat that could very easily be a war
crime and those people once identified
could be put on trial and this may be a
circumstances where where the foreign
office should should go in fighting
for now though sean pinner and aiden
aslan have a month to appeal if that
fails they could face death by firing
squad
dominic waghorn sky news